hey guys while according to a theory of
mine Ari will kill a major character in
the season finale a character that is
among a few others guilty for
destruction of her family
there's also high possibility that Ari
will start a new season with killing the
phrase in the season 6 finale Aria
killed Walder Frey along with his two
sons and there is most certainly high
possibility of Kirk killing the
remaining phrase in the first episode by
using the face she has stolen from the
Hall of faces or even with the face of
Walder Frey I know that if you haven't
watched all of my previous videos it
might sound out of the realm of
possibilities but a few months ago it's
been revealed that according to the
official agency resume of an actor David
Bradley to us known as Walder Frey will
appear in the upcoming season of Game of
Thrones
however Walder Frey is not coming back
his throat had been slit open he's dead
but Arya Stark wearing boulders face to
kill her meaning phrase to explain why
nectar did portrays Walder Frey was
according to his agency resume filming
scenes for the seventh season you're
most likely wondering have ilaria
managed to kill all the phrase by
herself well in my opinion Ari will not
kill the phrase one by one but will
rather use Wohlers face to set up a huge
meeting that will attend all the
remaining phrase for partial poison
either their food or drinks are using a
poison to kill her enemies might have
actually been foreshadowed in previous
seasons there's a scene in the 8th
episode of the fourth season in which
the hound and Arya are discussing
Joffrey's death while walking towards
the bloody gate The Hound states that
Geoffrey deserved to die but poison is a
woman's weapon on Acharya replied with
that's why you'll never be a great
killer little [ __ ] deserve to die but
poison poisons a woman's weapon man kill
steal stupid pride talking it's why
you'll never be a great killer
if Arya truly kills every single fraid
then Arya in this photo might be at
Riverrun the former seat of house Tully
is upon killing the phrase she would
most likely release her uncle Edmure
Tully who is phrase prisoner situated in
one of the cells as Walder Frey
mentioned himself on the celebration if
this theory proves true that event will
surely be one of the main events of the
upcoming season premiere if you're
wondering why didn't I include this
event in my breakdown of the first
episode it's simply because this event
is not confirmed by the promotional
photos nor backed up with some strong
proof while all those events that
in that video are in conclusion Arya
Starks role in the upcoming season will
be more than interesting Arya will
finally arrive home at Winterfell which
is not surprising at all since our title
to jackin her guard herself who she
really is and where she's heading a girl
is Arya Stark of Winterfell and I'm
going home on her way home she will have
a few encounters and most likely reunite
with her daughter Rolfe Lemuria it's
also easy to assume that Tara will most
likely continue avenging her family
while killing all the phrase by using
the face of older Frey would most
certainly be the great start of a season
if you would like to hear more details
about the theory that I mentioned in the
very beginning of this video if you
would like to hear more details about
Arya killing a man that is responsible
for destruction of her house feel free
to check out a video of mine by the name
the white wedding and as always let me
know your thoughts about all of this in
the comment section down below